[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Woo-hoo!
Way to set the scene.
Welcome, everyone.
Welcome.
Welcome, Arinzé.
ARINZÉ KENE: Hi.
How you doing?
SPEAKER: Welcome to Google.
Absolutely delighted
to have you here.
ARINZÉ KENE: It's a
pleasure to be here.
SPEAKER: Fabulous.
We're going to kick off
straight into it off the bat.
I'm going to first
do a quick intro
about "Misty," what
we just saw here,
and then a snippet about you.
And then we'll start
to really just unpack
with questions, if
that's cool for you.
ARINZÉ KENE: That's cool.
SPEAKER: So "Misty,"
following a sold out
run at the Bush Theatre, it
then transferred to the West End
at Trafalgar Studios--
which, to my understanding,
it's a limited season.
But did it just
recently get extended?
ARINZÉ KENE: It just got
extended to November the 17th.
SPEAKER: Which is
amazing, so no small feat.
This is awesome.
Well done.
It's described in one line--
if I had to block a line
out-- a lyrical journey
through the heart and
soul of inner city London.
So we'll unpack
that in a minute,
if that's cool with you.
ARINZÉ KENE: It's cool.
SPEAKER: Off the bat from
my perspective, having
seen the show last week--
it's undoubtedly a phenomenal
performance, I have to say.
And it's a really
captivating show.
For me, I thought
that the formats--
like there's genres from
physical theater is in there--
prose to verse, music that
sometimes feels like you're
at a concert for a
moment, and then it
switches to something else.
There's comedy in
there, as well.
But underlined you have some
really meaningful themes
and storyline.
And so I thought it
seamlessly blended together.
And for the X amount of time--
I don't even know, frankly,
how much time I was there for.
But I was just--
ARINZÉ KENE: You were
there for 10 years.
SPEAKER: For 10 years?
[LAUGHTER]
ARINZÉ KENE: For 10 years,
I didn't want it to stop,
'cause it was fantastic.
And it was.
Yeah.
I was like, no.
I wasn't ready.
I was saying at the ending I
wasn't ready for it, actually.
I won't spoil anything.
So seamlessly blended.
So congratulations
on the acclaim
you've had for the play,
and through the press.
Because I certainly
understand it.
ARINZÉ KENE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: And then,
of course, just
to set the scene and sort
of mentioned your CV--
as it were-- you're
not new to this.
You've done extensive
stage work--
"Lion King," "Girl From
the North Country,"
"One Night in Miami,"
just to name a few.
Starred in a variety of films,
TV, including "Eastenders"
for a while, and then
an upcoming movie,
"Been So Long," with Michaela.
Is it Michaela or Michaela?
ARINZÉ KENE: Michaela.
SPEAKER: Michaela Coel.
And then, of course,
you write books, plays.
Did I read seven?
Seven?
ARINZÉ KENE: I don't know.
SPEAKER: You don't even know.
OK.
Let's go with--
ARINZÉ KENE: I stopped counting.
SPEAKER: --a good number of
plays and screenplays, as well.
So you're part of--
is it-- well,
you'll tell me what
you're a part of in a
minute, if that's OK.
This is sort of like your--
so in a nutshell, that's
part of a very small
part of your CV.
Beyond that I just
want to also just give
a snippet about beyond the CV.
So you're born in
Lagos, Nigeria.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yes.
SPEAKER: You were raised then--
when you were young,
you moved to London
and then based in Hackney.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
Decided to leave
when I was three.
SPEAKER: You just
decided to leave?
ARINZÉ KENE: I was
like, I had enough.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: I had enough.
Yeah.
I'm going to try something new.
OK, awesome.
And then years later--
obviously not when
you were three--
you then, so cast your mind
forward many, many years--
you went to university.
I want to pick on this point.
And you studied--
ARINZÉ KENE: Well--
[LAUGHTER]
ARINZÉ KENE: --this is the bit--
SPEAKER: Tell me
about your journey--
ARINZÉ KENE: This
is the bit where--
SPEAKER: --to becoming
a successful actor.
ARINZÉ KENE: --there's
some misinformation.
SPEAKER: OK.
ARINZÉ KENE: So I
didn't go to uni.
SPEAKER: Ah.
Great.
ARINZÉ KENE: I was accepted.
I decided instead to
give acting a shot.
Yeah.
I was going to go and
study physiotherapy.
SPEAKER: Right.
ARINZÉ KENE: And
then I was like,
I don't want to be
fixing Tony's knee.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
I'd rather be on
stage Messing up
my knee, which I've been doing.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: So yeah, that's
what happened in 2006.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So you just went--
so tell us a bit about that
journey to now becoming
a successful actor.
Because I suspect many,
many people-- certainly
I know it having been
an actor for a while--
that it is no easy industry.
And it genuinely isn't.
So how did that come about?
And what does that entail?
Tell us about that journey.
ARINZÉ KENE: Sure.
Well, I guess, so one thing that
I kind of got from my family,
I would say, is grit is
just like, hard work.
I realized early on when
I started performing,
that a lot of people had
the same dreams as me.
[LAUGHTER]
And I was like,
how do I stand out?
You know, what do I do in
order to kind of just excel,
but also to be undeniable.
You know?
To kind of people
to kind of go, yeah.
We want that guy, not
like, one of these guys.
You know?
Yeah.
I know it sounds a bit weird.
But that's actually
what I saw as success--
people knowing that they want
me, specifically-- not just
a guy who can fit this thing.
You know?
And so over the last
12 and a half years
I've been working on that--
on being quite specifically me
as an artist, as a creative.
And I guess acting has
been a massive part of it--
showing people what I can
do on stage, on screen.
But also, the work
that I create,
which I've been quite nervous
about over the years--
about being honest about
what I love to make.
Because I feel like the type
of work that I make now,
"Misty" is closest to--
it's probably my
most honest work.
In fact, it is by far.
I've written other plays
that have been honest.
But I have been kind of
battling with, I guess,
the creative mind.
You battle with second
guessing your own work.
And you kind of read
pre-existing work.
And you kind of go, OK, cool.
So maybe mine has this
kind of be similar to that.
And, you know, also
with certain things
I've written in
the past, I kind of
was writing to this phantom
structure that existed,
and some people call it
like an orthodox kind
of structure or a traditional
approach to play writing.
And over the last few years,
I don't know what's happened.
But I just kind of really
quite tired of having
a lack of structure to write to.
And so I've really
kind of wrestled
with my demons artistically,
and "Misty" came out.
And "Misty" is like--
everyone who's been involved
in it feels pretty proud of it.
Because I don't think
there's much like it.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
ARINZÉ KENE: I mean, you sat
there for 10 years and you
didn't even know.
SPEAKER: Didn't know I
was there for 10 years.
I could've gone on longer.
No, exactly.
I think that, yeah, I
certainly would echo.
That was my impression
of that work.
And it sounds like you
had to get there, and to
where you are today.
That grit, tenacity,
determination,
knowing what you want--
I guess two questions.
How did you know
what you wanted?
And what support have you
had, you know, whether it's
your family or your
friends on that journey?
'Cause it's a tough journey.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
It was tough.
So from, I guess, when
I was a kid when I moved
to London to East London--
'91-- I have a kind of
very traditional Nigerian
family in the sense
that you had I
guess three or four options
about what you could be.
You know?
You can either be--
[LAUGHTER]
You guys-- doctor--
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I hear laughter there.
Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: What's
the other one?
AUDIENCE: Engineer.
ARINZÉ KENE: Engineer.
Lawyer.
Accountant.
That's about it, isn't it?
You know, it's kind of like--
and then all the other
bits that kind of, I guess,
it you're a pharmacist,
then that's all right.
Because you studied medicine.
You know what I mean?
It's close enough.
If you don't have the
doctor, then who are you?
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
So that was the kind of like--
that was the path that was,
I guess, laid out for me.
You know?
That was the reason why my
dad brought us all over,
so we could become those things.
And so while later
in life I was given
the freedom of what
to study, this thing
had been instilled in me.
And even when I had
the choice of what
to choose to study
in sixth form,
I went and chose chemistry,
biology, photography,
[INAUDIBLE].
You know, but the
chemistry and biology--
I wasn't really into
it-- not really.
I mean, I knew I was--
I knew I could memorize
things, you know?
And so that kind of
gave me the impression
that I was sort of good at it,
because I could memorize stuff.
But you have to have a
passion for it, don't you?
And so we came to a compromise--
my family-- my dad and I, that
I would study physiotherapy.
However, there was this kind
of raging undercurrent in me
all through my teens.
And it was just saying, perform.
Get on stage.
Do your thing.
You know?
And I would have these secret
conversations with people,
like relatives, like
imagine if, I don't know,
I was to just jump on a
stage and do something.
But I would never kind of
really give myself a chance.
Over the years-- so for example,
when I was in my early teens
I joined a youth company.
And I was doing stuff
on the weekends when
I wasn't playing basketball--
never invited my
family to see anything.
Because I knew it would
just be shut down city.
Yeah.
So this gap year
thing, you know,
I kind of went into it
knowing that I would never go,
because that would have
been soul destroying.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
I wouldn't change
a thing, as well.
Because by the time that things
started kicking off as far
as by getting professional
work, I was so grateful.
Because if it was something
that I felt like I couldn't do,
like I felt like I
wasn't allowed to do.
And yeah, even for a
few years when things--
I guess when I got
the ball rolling,
it was still very
hard to convince
my family that this
is going to work
and this is what I'm doing now.
SPEAKER: Are they convinced now?
[LAUGHTER]
Surely now they're convinced.
ARINZÉ KENE: No.
They are.
SPEAKER: OK.
ARINZÉ KENE: But it's funny.
It's weird.
The job that convinced
my dad that I
was going to be all right--
all he wanted to know was that
I was going to be all right.
SPEAKER: Sure.
ARINZÉ KENE: I mean, you know, I
won't criticize him for wanting
me to be a doctor or
a lawyer, or whatever.
Because those were the things
that, according to him,
kind of ensured that you
would have a really good life
and you would be able to look
after your family and so on.
Yeah.
You mentioned "Eastenders".
You know, and the
thing is right.
It's funny.
It's just funny, the ones
that, I guess, family respond
to-- people really respond to.
But when I got that, which
was my first television job,
he was--
I guess it was a massive
weight off his shoulders.
And he was like, you know what?
I'm watching my
son on television
with these characters
that I've been
watching for like, 10 years.
And you're there.
Yeah.
After that I was given a much--
I don't know, a lot
less of a hard time.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: Even though he
did still ask me a couple years
after that, so when
you going back to uni?
I was like, I don't know, man.
I was like, that
degree is going to have
to be an honorary thing.
SPEAKER: It might be.
Absolutely.
ARINZÉ KENE: I'm
not going, Pops.
SPEAKER: I'm not going.
ARINZÉ KENE: I'm not going.
SPEAKER: I'm not going, Dad.
No.
Yeah.
No, absolutely.
As a parent, I can
definitely understand.
Although I was
very much like no,
I'm going to do what
I'm going to do--
but now that I am a parent
and that's four of them,
I can definitely see.
I have actually said the words--
I couldn't believe it--
where I was like oh,
what about being a doctor?
Like, yeah.
Pharmacist came up.
I couldn't believe
what I was saying,
from the background that I had.
So it's interesting, as well.
So now that you are
where you're at,
how aware are you
of the influence
that you can have on others?
You said that you
knew what you wanted,
and you wanted to
convince others
that you need they needed
you-- the world needs you
in doing what you do, So
how aware are you one,
of the influence you
have on others now.
And what are they-- if
you know the influences
you have on people?
ARINZÉ KENE: Well,
that's the thing.
You can never quite
know, can you?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: I mean, some people
wait after the play is done
and kind of tell me what
they thought of it and how it
affected them.
Or some people write.
I always read everything.
SPEAKER: Do you?
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
You know, some people write.
And it's always humbling
to see, I guess, the impact
that I have as a creative.
And it's also eye opening.
And I've really thought
about it over the years.
I think that's a great question.
Because I've learned so much
through story in my life,
as in from when you're a kid you
know you're watching cartoons
and you're learning about how
to share through this cartoon
episode you watched
that's about sharing.
And it's like, never stops--
learning through story.
And you also learn really
bad things about yourself
through story, which
happened to me growing up.
You know, it's no
secret but some
of the depictions of young
black men and women in the world
is shocking.
You know?
And kind of repeating
certain work over and over--
you know, as a young man I'd
sit there and not having--
I guess not knowing what to
watch, I'd watch that, too.
And then I'd start thinking
a certain thing about myself.
Because every time
I turn on the telly,
it's like the black guy
has got to be the criminal.
And so, you know, it's about I
guess thinking about all that--
how complex that whole thing is.
Yeah.
It has informed
my work, in a way.
It's a real thing-- story.
It can change people's lives.
It can make them--
you know, I mean, it can
take a person off the ledge.
It's like, if you have
the capacity or the will,
the want to tell story,
then you do have a freedom.
But I also feel a sense of duty.
Because if I just know a little
bit about what impact creating
can have, and that's
just creating as a whole.
Not even particularly play
writing, but just that.
SPEAKER: Just being that person
out there who's aware of it
and doing whatever it is
that you might be doing.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So segueing into "Misty" now and
just thinking about-- actually
there's a point
in your play here
where you mention
around the point
that you just mentioned
now around what
do people see on TV.
You know?
And so anyway, so that's
mentioned in the play.
And I thought that was
a really apt moment
in the play, when you mentioned
like, what are the role models?
What do we see?
Why are certain films super
successful and others not?
Why can't we just see this?
I'm not trying to
spoil it, so I'm
kind of talking cryptically.
So anyway, so what drove and
inspired you to write "Misty?"
Yeah.
How did it come about--
either tactically, tangibly,
or like, from within the heart?
How did this come about?
ARINZÉ KENE: So I was
commissioned in 2012
by the Bush Theatre.
I had no idea what to write.
And I told those guys.
Those were like
Madani Younis, who's
the artistic
director of the Bush.
I told him at a time that
I might not write anything
for a hot minute.
With me, with my head--
a hot minute was a year.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: And had you
written-- just to check,
had you written before that?
You've been writing?
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: OK.
So they commissioned based
on stuff they'd seen you do?
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
SPEAKER: Or just a hunch?
What was it?
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
Madani had seen a play called
"Little Baby Jesus," which
I had on at the
Oval House Theatre.
And then it went to
Latitude Festival.
And I think he
saw it at Latitude
and then met with me in 2012.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
That hot minute turned out
to be three hot minutes--
three years later.
That's when I kind
of, I got the idea
about what I wanted to write--
sort of, anyway.
And then I kind of
challenge myself
and I thought it was a
little bit too challenging
to tackle that idea.
And so I kind of
tried to chicken out.
I tried to pay Madani
the commission back.
Yeah.
I was like, look, man.
I can't really--
I can't deliver.
And he said, just
take your time.
I didn't commission a play.
A commissioned the writer.
You know, there is no deadline.
Just kind of take your time.
And I'm so glad he did that,
because we wouldn't have
"Misty" if he didn't.
Because I just kind of
thought about it again,
but from a different place.
This is when, as
I said, I decided
to be more honest
about it-- you know,
about the work I was making.
Yeah.
"Misty"-- inspirations
around it.
One, growing up in Hackney.
Coming back to Hackney.
Seeing how much
Hackney has changed.
I guess meeting up
with mates in cafes
and talking about that
place that used to be there,
now that's gone and it's
turned into this now.
Kind of like putting all
those ideas together and all
those feelings together
and laughing about it--
and also kind of
like just helping
to organize your thoughts
and your emotions.
"Misty" is kind of--
and I don't think this
gives away too much.
But I play two
characters in "Misty."
Right?
And it's kind of like a--
so there's two storylines
running parallel.
And then they begin
to interweave.
One of them is the character--
well, we can call him Lucas.
And I guess he's wondering
what's happening in this area.
You know, he's quite
frustrated with what
we learn through the
play is gentrification.
That story is like
an extended metaphor.
You know, it's told in
quite a separate world.
It feels quite surreal.
And then there is this
other quite absurd story
line, which I'm playing.
I'm playing a character whose
name is Arinzé, who is--
it's a fictional, kind of
surreal version of myself.
And those scenes
are quite absurd.
But that is me navigating
through this creative industry.
That Arinzé is
also a playwright,
and also has to deliver
plays, and also has to talk
to producers, and his agent.
And the play that he's writing
is the play that we're seeing.
So that's the Lucas story.
And then they begin
to kind of crossover,
and you're not sure in the end--
you're not sure who's who.
But that is what Misty is.
It kind of holds a mirror
in between Lucas and Arinzé.
It shows you, I guess,
similarities in their world--
similar challenges.
Because I've had
my own obstacles
as a writer-- trying
to create honest work,
and also trying to, I guess,
to basically to just battle
these demons all the time.
You know?
And yeah, without
giving too much away,
that's kind of like--
SPEAKER: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's great--
ARINZÉ KENE: That's kind
of the overlook of it all.
SPEAKER: And I'll
say final question
before we move to the audience.
So I have your questions ready,
because I could talk all night.
But it's not fair.
How have the
audiences responded?
How do you feel it's
been responded--
they've responded
to specifically
in this branch of
Trafalgar Studios?
I don't know if it's
any different than Bush,
but tell us.
ARINZÉ KENE: No.
Yeah, it's not actually
that different.
I mean, the Bush
was really good.
Because, well, it
SPEAKER: You out.
ARINZÉ KENE: We sold out,
and then we extended.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: And
then we sold out.
And now we have been doing
really well in the West End--
so much so that we've sold out.
I mean, well, not
sold out-- sorry--
but we've extended
to November the 17th.
And so we're going for
another month on top
of what we were meant to do.
That is a treat.
More people get
to see this story.
For me, I mean, if you ask about
what the audience feedback has
been, we wouldn't
be in the West End
if it weren't for audiences.
You know, they brought us here.
You know, they came.
And they came to the Bush
and they sold us out.
You know, and then
they extended us,
and then they were the ones who
were demanding that they wanted
more "Misty" because their
family members hadn't
come to see it, and because
of like, more people need to.
And so that would
be the kind of--
for me, that's number one.
Because if there's no demand,
then what do you have?
So that's why we're
there in the West End.
And then on the nightly
basis, you know, it's good.
The play is really--
I mean, it's a play that I
get to play with the audience
every night.
You know?
I break the fourth wall.
You know, I talk to you
guys about something.
If stuff gets weird
in the theater--
which sometimes it does--
I have the capacity to stop
the scene and to engage.
And so yeah, it's
been really special.
You know?
It's really like, I can't--
I mean, I think we all
struggle to describe "Misty,"
including my director, as well.
Because it's so different
on every night, because
of this kind of relationship
that I have with the theater,
and what the audience are
giving me at that time.
Because I'm clowning a little
bit in that show, as well.
And just like a small
element like that
can change everything.
Because with clowning,
you're responding to what
an audience is giving you.
And so like, if
you're really loving
when I do this thing
tonight, then I
might go a little bit further.
And if you love it even more,
then I'll go even further.
And if you love even more,
then I'll go even further--
until the point where--
I mean, and literally,
we're milking it.
You know?
[LAUGHTER]
But that's the thing.
You know?
And we've had quite a
few of those moments
where the difference between
one scene the night before
and that night is
like, night and day.
You know, it's because of
the audience are giving me
something, I'm responding
to it in the moment.
SPEAKER: Yeah, absolutely.
That definitely was the
impression I got when I saw it.
Yeah.
I like it.
I'd specifically use a
word like captivating.
Because when I was wondering
in my head like gosh, you know.
Also, you do this every single--
like, eight shows a week.
Right?
But it felt very much like
your energy was just like,
this is one off.
I've never done this before.
So kudos to you on
that, just the energy.
And it's good to hear
that you kind of read
and feed off the audience.
And I think it does make
a holistic experience.
So thank you for that.
ARINZÉ KENE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Shall we
move to Q and A?
Let's move to Q and A. So
there is a mic at the back.
ARINZÉ KENE: Just
standing there alone.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So we do need folks to
stand up at the mic.
Yeah, absolutely.
So thank you.
Yeah.
I should probably
mention that there will
be a mic stand at the back.
Wonderful.
So if you could state your
name, if you're happy to.
And then, yeah,
question nice and loud.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My name is [INAUDIBLE]
raised the same way as you
in Nigeria and Hackney--
still in Hackney.
So I completely understand
the frustrations
that you illustrated
throughout the play.
I wanted to ask a few things,
but I'll start with this one.
The cross media convergence
in the play was incredible.
And I wanted to know, how did
you come up with that idea?
Because even with the
use of space as well,
it's unlike anything I've
seen before in my life.
You are literally breaking the
fourth wall with those mediums,
as well--
which again, I don't think
I'll ever see anyone do it
as well as you.
So I wanted to know how
did you come up with that?
And did you predict
the effect it would
have on the people watching?
Because it's so seamless.
Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
I've actually never been
asked so specifically
that question before.
But that is-- as in the
question about predicting what
an audience would respond to.
So we're being smart asses in
"Misty" quite a bit, actually.
So we think you're--
we try and take
you a bit this way.
And then oh, you think
you're going that way.
And then things take
a right you know?
And then we go, all right, cool.
We're staying on course for a
bit, and then pull the rug--
but without making an
audience feel silly.
You know what I mean?
Because that's a fine line.
You have to kind of do
it playfully and make
them feel like, ah,
didn't see that coming.
But one of our
ways of doing that
is through playing
with the form.
OK.
We got lucky, because "Misty"
is a telling of that story.
Right?
But we decided-- and by we I
mean me and Omar, my director--
to approach it from a way
where so we're just doing what
is best to serve the story.
Right?
So we're not restricted
by any sort of,
as I mentioned earlier,
pre-existing structures as far
as what a traditional play looks
like on the page, or wherever.
Even if you open
the play text, it
doesn't look like
a traditional play.
Because we're using
many different mediums.
And as well, the play
text wouldn't even--
it's not even possible
to completely--
I mean that doesn't show you--
you can't read it and
know what the play is.
Because there's performance
art in there, as well,
that you can't--
I mean, you'd need
100 pages to explain
every thing, every turn that
I do, and repetitive movement,
or whatever.
I digress.
So because we approached
this from a standpoint
where we were saying
let's do whatever we can--
whatever's best in order
to tell the story--
it meant that some
bits we were like, OK.
Some days you can
do direct address.
And some bits you can jump
into song, into number.
And it feels like a gig.
And then because of at this
point the writer feels this,
let's just undercut that
and go into this over here.
Now when you're creating
a play that does that,
you come up against
certain challenges.
Certain people might think
oh, it's too experimental.
Will it work, or whatever.
And we came up against those,
I guess, types of feedback.
Good feedback, I'd say.
It's just because
of people, you know,
they're used to a certain thing.
And they would read what
I've written and think,
oh, I thought this
was a bit jarring.
You know, I don't know.
I'm used to reading something
that kind of flows better.
But "Misty" was,
like every play,
is written to be performed.
You know?
And so we knew that we needed to
do some sort of sharing of it.
We needed to show you, rather
than send you a script.
And so there was a radar
festival at the end of 2015.
The Bush do a festival of
work that is work in progress.
And they also receive work
from outside, as well,
that might be complete.
But as I was on
commission there,
we thought this is
a great opportunity
to do 40 minutes
of this crazy ish
that we've been kind of
throwing around the wall,
and just show people that
actually this might work.
And we didn't even know
if it'd work, anyway.
But we had a feeling
that it would.
So yeah, we did two performances
to paying audiences.
So that was like,
a normal audience.
So it's not like an audience of
peers, or friends, or whatever.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Honest feedback.
ARINZÉ KENE: It was
an honest-- yeah.
And we realized that oh,
we have something special.
Let's do more of this.
And also, as far as kind of
changing me being on stage,
slash, me like a
prerecord or this, that--
we realized that all
that stuff works.
You know?
And after that sharing,
I think the main kind
of thing we gathered was to go
even further down the rabbit
hole.
And so that's why
we have "Misty."
And also, we're not
even done with it,
if I'm honest with you, bro.
Like as in this is
where we are now.
But the "Misty" in West
End-- we improved on it.
With a week's rehearsal,
we improved on
is from when it
was on at The Bush.
Some people come and
see it in the West End
and say that they
feel like they're
watching it for the first time.
It's because we tweaked so much.
We changed small things that we
thought people wouldn't notice.
But people have come
away and gone like,
that wasn't there before.
That was not there before.
Was it?
I didn't miss that.
SPEAKER: They hold you to it.
ARINZÉ KENE: And I think
if it has another leg,
there's also some more things
out myself and Omar are willing
to want to put in there.
SPEAKER: Fabulous.
Thank you.
Next question?
We've got time, don't worry.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
SPEAKER: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So you've said
that making honest mark
is really important to you.
And I think you've
always done that.
So I've known you since
you was an artist called
Street Journalist.
I remember listening to the
album and just tweeting you,
I love it.
Street Journalist, "I am, I
am," is like, my favorite track.
Did you ever foresee this
journey from that space?
So when you were
Street Journalist,
did you foresee this
journey from that space?
ARINZÉ KENE: Firstly,
frickin' gold stars.
[LAUGHTER]
Wow.
You took me back.
Street Journalist was my artist
name when I was in a few bands,
and I used to write rhymes--
hip hop.
Released mix tapes
and stuff in my teens.
Yeah, yeah.
In my teens.
SPEAKER: And did your
dad know about this?
Did you keep that--
ARINZÉ KENE: Listen.
[LAUGHTER]
ARINZÉ KENE: He don't
know about this, too.
That would have been the
end of Street Journalist.
But, no.
Yeah.
You're right, actually.
I was honest when I was writing
rhymes when I was a teenager.
I felt like I was being honest.
Something happened
along the way,
when I got into playwriting,
where I definitely
took a step away.
I feel like with Street
Journalist, I was writing.
I was writing for me, as
in the was no character.
You know, it was like that
was the name of the artist.
But those were my
words and I was
speaking about my experiences.
And then when you start to
create characters, you know,
I feel like maybe
that was what it was.
Who knows?
But yeah, I just started
getting a bit phony.
And then I would still say that
I guess the plays I've written
are--
you know, they have a
lot of my heart in it.
But I definitely know that--
and a lot of writers will
say this, as well-- but
some things you write are
more honest than others.
And it's just the case where
you can kind of get deeper.
I didn't foresee this happening.
In fact, when I
started writing plays,
I think I started
writing when I was 19.
And I actually gave up music.
I kind of stepped back.
I stepped away from it.
Yeah.
"Misty is the first time I've
put music back into my work.
And I quite like it.
You know, that's why it
was also really quite fun.
It felt like I was
in my bedroom again,
you know, just kind
of writing bars.
But no, I didn't see this.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
Yeah, definitely the musical
aspect-- the enjoyment--
I got that impression
that you were really
enjoying it, the music
piece of the performance.
So it was good.
ARINZÉ KENE: I feel lucky.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Tony.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my name's Tony.
I know--
ARINZÉ KENE: Your name's Tony?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ARINZÉ KENE: Who are you, man?
AUDIENCE: I know Arinzé
from playing basketball--
ARINZÉ KENE: We go way back.
AUDIENCE: --when I
first moved to London.
Great guy.
Not a great basketball
player, but we're not going--
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just kidding.
I'm kidding.
But one thing I do want to say--
I got to see the show
a couple weeks ago.
It was excellent.
It was interesting.
I was excited to
come see you perform.
I'd seen you in the "Girl
from the North Country."
I was excited to see this.
I was a bit skeptical.
I was like, it's going to be
you for however many hours,
or however many years.
I was like, what's this
going to feel like?
But I think the
real testament to it
was when we got to
the intermission.
And my partner was there, and
she had a half a drink left.
And she was like, wow.
I didn't even drink this.
And she's Scottish, and
that was a big thing.
[LAUGHTER]
So we were absolutely
captivated, right?
[LAUGHTER]
She's going to kill me
for telling that story.
But the one thing I do want to
say, or I want to ask you by
is around the comedy
aspect-- the humor to it.
I personally find there's
one particular song in it
that I was like,
really taken back by.
And I was in it,
and I was really
kind of upset, challenged
thinking about it.
It was pretty hard
going, and you're talking
about some serious issues.
And then you jump to an
interesting kind of scene,
just before the intermission for
those that have seen it-- where
you add humor and comedy to it.
So I'm really interested
in the journey
around how you effectively
try and use humor
to kind of soften that blow.
Or what's the thinking behind
using comedy alongside very,
very serious issues?
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
That's a really good question.
Yeah.
It's just weird.
It's Tony.
[LAUGHTER]
It's Tony from the courts.
You know, I'm just--
SPEAKER: He's asking
you a question.
ARINZÉ KENE: I'm just used to
playing basketball with Tony.
No.
First of all, I'd just like to
say that I'm coming back from
my frickin' mate--
I'm coming back to the courts.
I haven't been for a while, and
Tony's getting pretty cocky.
You know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ARINZÉ KENE: And I think he's
forgotten about my crossover.
So I'm coming back
to lace you, mate.
No.
I love playing
basketball with you.
But yeah, I guess it's
like music, isn't it?
So we definitely know what we're
doing whenever we kind of take
an audience.
It's like we kind of
grab them by the hair,
and then we take 'em, take 'em,
take 'em under, deep, deep.
And then it's like,
it's really dark.
And then we just kind of go
woo, and just pull them up.
And then they're
gasping for air.
We do that a lot in the play.
We undercut quite serious
moments with levity,
with humor, with something
quite absurd or unexpected.
And we did it a few times.
And the reason why is because
we know that audiences
like how that feels.
You get to purge, don't you?
You know, you get
to kind of just--
you know, you kind
of go, oh, man.
Woo!
Well, that wasn't-- yeah.
I mean, I'm glad that
I'm in there anymore.
And it's playful.
It's a dance.
You know?
The comedy, as well, the
humor, and the clowning,
and the absurdity, and also
some of the surreal moments
that feel quite comical--
those are things that we--
well, as a performer I
want to be doing more of.
In my work, I haven't been given
the chance to a great deal.
But I love comedy.
I love to make people laugh.
I think that when you do--
So another thing that we've
realized is that when you do
make them laugh, then
you could actually--
I'm saying them.
I mean, fuck it.
But with story, it's
a give and a take.
You know?
And you don't have
to do anything.
I like to entertain and then
educate, or entertain and then
challenge.
And that's it.
You know?
It's like, you know, sometimes I
see as basic as a boxing match.
You know?
So you get your three
minutes in the ring,
and then you get rest.
And that rest feels really nice.
You know, you get some
sugary drink and some old man
rubbing your shoulders.
[LAUGHTER]
And you're getting told in
your ears that you're great.
You know?
And you know that
there's more to go.
There's a longer fight.
And with audiences, it's
like there's a push and pull.
And that's how I like
to tell a story, anyway.
I like to talk about
something that's meaningful.
I like to challenge something
that is very often quite
a difficult challenge for me.
But then while I'm
doing it, I always
ask are they being entertained.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
And comedy can
really build rapport.
And then you can talk about
the more meaningful things.
ARINZÉ KENE: Start
building rapport.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
Thank you.
That's awesome.
We'll go with final question,
if that's all right.
And then we'll wrap up.
Because we've got
a show to go to.
Hello, hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, Arinzé.
My name is Ivan.
I had a question
around-- so I'm really
interesting in the
creative process.
And what advice would
you give in someone
that's creating something--
it could be anything.
How do you manage
your mindset, and then
to go you're trying to achieve?
So basically, just
what is your advice
in terms of going through
this crazy process
to produce "Misty?"
ARINZÉ KENE: If I could
say one thing only,
it would be start
before you're ready.
Because everyone-- everyone--
myself, yes, always
waiting for a moment.
You know?
We're waiting until I'm smart
enough to tell that story,
or until I know enough about
that subject to tell a story,
or until I feel whatever,
or whatever, until my son
graduates.
You can be waiting forever.
You know?
Just start.
Just kick off.
Find out what-- in whichever
way you choose to do it.
Whether it's that you want to--
you set a very basic goal for
yourself and say, OK, cool.
Let me just write one
line of this thing, first.
Or whether it's like
you go, all right, cool.
I'm going to write the
end of the play now.
Or if it's a play, or whatever.
That would be why would say if
I had one thing-- just start.
Because I feel like if you
have a creative mind, one
of the best things--
one of the things
that are incredibly
useful for the
creative mind is doubt.
Right?
And the reason why my opinion,
is because without doubt you
wouldn't have scrutiny.
And I think in order to
scrutinize your work, in order
to interrogate it yourself--
that's what makes good work.
You have to test it.
However, that is also the
thing that prevents people
from making work--
over testing, or interrogating
it too much before
you've even begun.
So while that doubt is
incredibly valuable,
don't let it prevent
you from beginning.
SPEAKER: Fabulous.
So one final question
to close out.
What's next for you?
And people can go look on and
IMDB for what's up next for you
in terms of your role.
But share with us one
dream or one aspiration.
What do you really want to do?
Just share an
aspiration with us.
I'm putting you
on the spot here.
ARINZÉ KENE: I feel it.
I can feel it.
I'm on the spot.
SPEAKER: We have time.
ARINZÉ KENE: Just one?
Yeah.
Creatively, to be even more--
to tell even just one
story, one more story,
where I've been as honest
as I have been there.
I'd be very happy.
I'll be incredibly
happy-- just one more.
Because for me, that is the--
that's why "Misty"
has been the hardest
thing I've ever done, ever.
Because of being so open.
Yeah.
And, you know, I actually
have a story in mind
that I plan to be
as honest with,
and I keep chickening out.
You know?
Because even knowing this--
like, even knowing that--
knowing that I have to be
brave to tell that story,
doesn't make you
brave to tell a story.
You know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: I still have
to kind of work my way up.
At the moment, I know what
I'm doing by procrastinating.
I'm kind of like, putting a
team together and going oh,
let's meet this
composer and let's--
SPEAKER: Getting the
infrastructure in place.
ARINZÉ KENE: I really
want that director.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: But you're not
focusing on actually the core.
ARINZÉ KENE: No.
SPEAKER: I think that's fair.
ARINZÉ KENE: I'm kind
of like, messing around.
You know?
I'm playing with
my food, you know?
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Yeah.
ARINZÉ KENE: But yeah, that
would be great, man-- you know,
for that one, anyway.
If I can be brave.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
Well, I mean, you've
definitely set the foundation
with "Misty."
So I think it's probably
very achievable.
I think many, many
people around the world
would probably really value
that, appreciate that, and look
forward to that.
So some people might
hold you to that.
But I'm wishing you
all the luck with that.
In the meantime,
"Misty," fantastic.
Have a wonderful show tonight.
ARINZÉ KENE: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you
for coming to see us.
Please come see us again.
ARINZÉ KENE: I will.
SPEAKER: It's been a pleasure.
Yeah.
Come see Tony again.
ARINZÉ KENE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER: Big round of applause.
Thank you so much.
ARINZÉ KENE: Cheers.
Thanks for having me.
[APPLAUSE]